para vir falar aqui tive que fazer as
melhores seleções da minha vida e das
piores também no cinema
chamamos de montagem e edição
na minha vida eu tive cenas de medo dor
e decepção mas esses sentimentos eles
não foram maiores do que o fato real de
querer perdoar e esquecer de levar aqui
dentro apenas o que foi bom o meu filme
continua em 2012 antes de fazer a
cirurgia bariátrica
fui diagnosticada com depressão resistir
por muito tempo a procurar uma terapia
eu sempre me questionava mas jô
pra que você precisa de terapia você
mora sozinha desde 18 anos viaja todo
mês
vai todo ano para o carnaval de salvador
ganha muito bem pois é é verdade existe
uma joana comprometida profissional
de bem com a vida pra todo mundo porém
existe uma outra impotente infeliz por
nunca ter tido um reconhecimento de
verdade sabe quando você deposita a sua
energia se mata fazer um trabalho e é um
outro que leva a fama pois é acontecia
seguidamente comigo
parecia que me faltava algo algo que eu
pudesse chegar e falar olha gente está
vendo isso aqui tá lindo né
foi o que fiz parece tosco mas quem
nunca há quatro anos foi desligada do
mundo corporativo com toda minha
estabilidade estrutura no mesmo ano
consigo uma oportunidade na área que eu
queria
ganhando bem menos mas era a
oportunidade mas parece até do euro que
eu vou contar pra vocês
pente tudo começou a desabar
junto com as novas atividades
vieram situações de assédio moral e um
relacionamento abusivo emissões
o sonho meu não era mais um conto de
fadas
vocês acreditam que eu cheguei a sentir
falta do mundo corporativo total da
história mas depressão e para se
recolocar currículos enviados salário
bem abaixo do que eu esperava o merecia
me sentia feia me sentia acabada às
vezes nem eu me aguentava de tão ranço
nem livro de auto ajuda nem banho de
ervas me sentia sozinha
doía tudo doía minha alma
mas eu sou capricorniana né
com essa ainda entre o leão nos dois
anos seguintes
comecei a fazer várias coisas para poder
conseguir dinheiro
gerenciado eventos escrevia projetos e
fazer a fotografia à aula
comecei a ami potencializar estudando
marketing digital
criei uma marca uma receita de amarula
artesanal que diga se de passagem gente
é maravilhosa mas no fundo no fundo eu
esperava que a minha hora da virada
chegasse numa dessas andanças de bazar e
feiras no rio de janeiro em 2016 foi
convidada para um piquenique brechó no
parque de madureira dia 2 de novembro eu
nunca vou esquecer essa data
ela simboliza tristeza e finados
mas esse dia foi o dia do meu
renascimento
além de conseguir ganhar 120 reais
naquele brechó nasceu a idéia virou pra
minha amiga e fala assim fazer uma feira
que mês que vem
olha eu achando que era só isso nem
sempre trabalhei com eventos e nunca
fiquei com essa parte burocrática
cheguei fazer uma feira aqui ela virou
vamos sim jogo
já falei que você tem que fazer alguma
coisa por você
aí eu saí molha sou produtor há culto à
ingenuidade ligo pra cá ea gente já
marca mas a gente tem que chegar com o
nome poderoso agente não pode chegar com
qualquer nome
a gente tem que chegar com alguma coisa
que seja diferente e que remeta algo é
que se diferencia das outras feiras que
anda acontecendo por aí e passamos o
final de semana pensando que no meio
ambiente e dá prazer
eu quero dar alguma coisa que remeta o
rio alguma coisa carioca 0 21 ddd da
cidade do rio de janeiro
mas ainda faltava o nome em poderá em
poder e até que em poderes e 0 21 a esse
o nome
nascia ali a plataforma multi cultural
de feiras de economia criativa do rio de
janeiro
as maggi os eventos de feira eles até
utilizavam o nome marca autoral mas a
expressão economia criativa ainda não
era habitual
eu vou contar pra você é você conhece a
lei da atração é quando a gente acredita
tanto numa coisa a gente depositar a
nossa energia naquela ali que tudo em
nossa volta acaba conspirando e as
pessoas também acaba acreditando e foi
assim vou contar pra vocês um pulo do
gato
nunca jamais em hipótese alguma
use expressões do tipo eu gostaria eu
queria eu adoraria não gente perdeu é
agora tem que se auto afirmar é chegar e
falar aquilo que realmente você quer
enviei e mail o parque de madureira
nós somos nós temos
nossas projeções e as palavras economia
criativa e desenvolvimento sustentável
responderam o e mail
adoramos o projeto quando vocês podem
ver o parque gente eu tremia
eu não sabia o que pensar eu gritava
chorava porque lembra quando eu contei
pra vocês lá atrás que eu esperava que a
hora da virada chegar estava ali na
minha frente e minha cabeça leonino já
estava pensando em fazer a primeira no
parque de madureira a segunda em santa
teresa e eu nem tinha conseguido ainda
autorização pro parque de madureira até
que começou aquelas opiniões geralmente
que vem de pessoas que nunca realizaram
nada mas adoram falar né
mas joana com que dinheiro vai fazer
essa feira 6 a jô
tu é louca coloca suas barraquinhas para
não ficar caro quem vai pagar hotel
eventos em conhecer vocês acham que não
vieram ver o pensamento de desistir
como eu ia conseguir dinheiro para poder
fazer um evento destes
quem ia vem investindo no evento
eu nunca tinha realizado no meu caixa
eu tinha dez reais mas a montagem do
projeto estava tão legal ea comunicação
estava tão redonda
primeiro vieram os amigos falando que o
sportng e pois vieram os artistas
querendo cantar e cantar gente sabe
quando eu percebi que o projeto ia dar
certo quando começaram a falar o evento
foi cancelado
o evento está muito caro é mais um
evento anunciar outras feiras
ali eu vi que é dar certo olha a minha
lua estava tão em vênus
e o meu sol está tão em marte que chegou
à minha amiga investidor anjo
depois chegou fornecedores artistas e
técnicos
tivemos até assessoria de imprensa e
banda tudo certo vocês acharam que não
era emoção né
liguei para o parque de madureira e aí
estou ligando só pra poder confirmar a
feira que é fera
como assim tudo marcado gente todo mundo
falando
e lá fomos nós para o parque de
madureira repassar o nosso lugar para
outra pessoa
sentamos com a administração olha aqui
olha o mapa dá lhe conseguimos gente
um recanto lindo sorte que ainda não
tinha mandado imprimir nada e de repente
chegou de 18 de dezembro que dia lindo
gente todo mundo em êxtase
parecia que todo mundo se conhecia né
todo mundo passando amigos de outras
cidade mandando boa vibração
todo mundo lá eu toda de branco com o
som maravilhoso vários cliques aquelas
pessoas que falaram que não ia dar certo
que me chamaram de louca também estavam
e assim vencendo meus dias com muito
choro e muita alegria muita diversão e
aí vocês acharam que acabou mas é lógico
que eu mandei um e mail para o parque
das ruínas gente
háháhá estava marcada a segunda edição
da empordef 0 21
lá começamos com 15 expositores
depois chegamos a 35 expositores teve
edição que chegou a 6 mil pacientes em
um dia só era só sair a próxima que já
escutava as vagas saímos em várias redes
de imprensa saímos é nem vou falar
as mídias mas nós éramos muito cobiçados
é empreender ter o meu próprio negócio
me fez enxergar o quanto foi importante
é trabalhar no mundo corporativo me fez
ser uma profissional multifuncional na
minha empresa eucatur capacita pessoas
cuida da comunicação faça a fotografia
faz edição faz uma autoria e cuida do
caixa
se eu quero mais
mas é lógico que eu quero mais não sou
rica mas hoje eu vivo do meu próprio
negócio o que aconteceu também é que de
uma mudança na na terra que melhorou o
zodíaco né melhorou meu céu e tudo isso
não teria acontecido se eu não tivesse
corrido à frente e não atrás
agora vou contar uma coisa pra vocês
vocês sabiam que joana d'arc a heroína
era uma cap coreana nata com ascendência
león
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]